[Music]
what's up everyone langston belton here
and i am joined by the stars and
creative team of marvel studios the
falcon and the winter soldier hello
everyone
all right let's get into it so we last
saw sam and bucky at the end of marvel
studios avengers end game what's changed
for these characters since then bucky
got some new pants
uh got a haircut sam also gained a few
new interesting gadgets the entire world
has changed because the blip happened
and they're both now going to have to
deal with the fallout the whole series
is born from that the existential crisis
of a black man dealing with the shield
bucky barnes and sam dealing with the
fact that the most important person in
their lives and the mcu is gone i think
most people say post blip but i think
for the two of them is post steve
they're trying to figure out how to
acclimate themselves to this new reality
sam has split back and so his family
life continued while he was gone and
he's coming back to have to try and
reintegrate into that and bucky has
changed and he is maybe healed maybe not
so this series covers a lot of ground
you know so i'd like to do that now too
i'm gonna name a person or thing and i
want you to tell me the first thing that
comes to your mind okay lightning round
yes yeah see took the words right out of
my mouth okay let's start
cap's shield is compromised is
redesigned sharon carter adulthood she's
our rock
zemo where's a lot of cologne
captain america a hero
monumental here's a question mark
oh
uh
uh loading oh look at that see yeah
yeah
you got that reference
falcon existential the superhero flies
high standing strong against the wind
oh god
okay the winter soldier also a hero
guilt
stairs ahead
looking for an opportunity
okay what are you most excited for fans
to see in the series you know we are a
six hour series so it means that um we
we are the meal if the movies are a
snack we're the meal we can be with the
characters for a much longer time and we
can go with them on adventures and
really get to know them that's a new
thing for for the
fans they haven't ever lived these
characters in the same way the amount of
time dedicated each of these heroes was
given a personal storyline not just
personal story beats an entire story
that has nothing to do with the bad guys
and all that
and those story lines are
fraught with emotion and are going to
force them characters to cave or emerge
as new people born of this moment but
the action i think you know we really
delivered so i i'm pretty sure that
they're gonna love not just the
characters but the action too
oh thank you all so much and all you out
there don't miss marvel studios the
falcon and the winter soldier streaming
exclusively on disney plus march 19.
[Music]
[Laughter]
like i mean we're laughing i know why
we're but like i don't even know if it's
funny or not i don't it's just us it's
we have so many inside jokes with these
characters i have a feeling they might
be a part of the big three
what big three the big three white pick
three androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely it
no it's not
you